au somma le sentier des calumés de Bras
Sec à palmiste rouge la curiosité de la
semaine le graveur sur cuivre de
silaos rendez-vous à silaos prendre en
direction du bloc puis de Bras Sec à
l'ombre du côau carvegen traverser le
village vous pourrez vous garer au
départ du
sentier pour cette randonnée de
difficulté moyenne de 4 km en allée
simple prévoir de quoi vous protéger de
la pluie et du soleil et une réserve
d'eau pour votre santé parcourez nos
sentiers à lappelomb de la paroi des
calumés 1000 m en dessous du sentier
Jacky Inard le sentier des calumés
permet de faire la jonction entre brass
et palmiste rouge deux des CIN
principaux het du cirque de
silaos réalisable dans les deux sens
cette randonnée est plus facile en
descente vers palmiste rouge partir de
brassex c'est aussi se garantir de beau
points de vue matinaux sur
silaos le temps de la première montée
jusqu'au petit plateau de La Mar à
monfleury un véritable écrin de nature
restaurée qui permet d'observer de
nombreuses
espèces
donc alors tu vois ici on arrive au au
plateau de la Mara monfleu donc avec le
le bonnet de prête sur notre droite donc
qui a fait l'objet le plateau qui a fait
l'objet d'une restauration alors on
retrouve pas mal d'espèces indigène des
haut en fait donc tu as le petit Mao tu
as derrière moi le fleur jaune tu as le
tamarin deso donc toute cette
restauration a permis de d'avoir ces
espèces là et du coup je sais pas si tu
entend derrière nous donc on entend les
oiseaux les oiseaux se sentent bien ici
et nous aussi d'autant que les zones de
plats avec des sentiers larges qui ne
sont pas des pistes forestières sont
rares à la
Réunion il faudra bien pourtant se
résoudre à quitter cet Eden pour plonger
dans la Ravine des calumés ici
l'ambiance change du tout au tout très
vite le sentier jalonné de bloc et très
envahi de jouvance donne une s
d'aventure à cette intersection le
sentier de gueule rouge sur la droite
permet de faire le tour du bonnet de
prêtre le sentier des calumés lui
continue tout
droit cette espèce très courante à silos
est une exotique envahissante qui menace
les forêts indigènes c'est le troen de
Sellan
en traversant la rivière le sentier se
rapproche maintenant d'impressionnantes
falaises à l' plom de la ravine dans
lesqueles niche des salonganes sorte
d'hirondelle et l'eau qui enensuinte
mouille en permanence le sentier
attention donc à ne pas
glisser palmiste rouge est maintenant en
vue avec près d'un millier d'habitants
il est le plus peuplé du cirque après
silaos palmiste rouge est aussi connu
pour être la ville d'origine de la
majorité des célèbres breuses et c'est
ici que se termine notre R
ce que j'aime dans cette randonnée donc
c'est en la faisant en partant d'ici
comme on a fait ce matin c'est quand on
arrive sur le plateau de La Mar à fleuie
donc on se retrouve sur vraiment on est
dans un milieu où il y a beaucoup
d'espèces indigènes dans la randonnée ce
que j'aime bien aussi c'est la traversée
des des de la rivière à plusieurs
endroits et là on peut trouver des des
coins agréables pour piquniquer il y a
différents accès pour cette randonnée
donc on peut partir effectivement de
Brass soit de palmistes rouge il y a
plusieurs accès depuis brassc donc on
peut faire aussi le tour du bonnet de
prête et on peut aussi prendre le bus
une fois arrivé au terminus à pas miste
rouge pour rejoindre silaous ce que
j'aime moins en fait c'est que on a
effectivement le côté minéral mais le
côté végétation et présent mais c'est
surtout des espèces c'est un milieu qui
est quand même assez dégradé en fait
donc on a effectivement le plateau qui
qui lui est très très joli et ensuite on
va arriver dans un milieu assez dégradé
avec des eucalyptus et différentes
espèces exotique
aussi technique séculaire en provenance
d'Allemagne la gravure à l'au forte sur
plaque de cuivre est perpétué en plein
cœur de la ville de silaos le graveur
sur cuivre est notre curiosité de la
semaine la gravur su cuivre c'est une
technique ancienne qui date du 15e
siècle à l'époque quand on avait pas de
moyen de reproduire les images et c'est
dérivé d'un métier d'orfèvre notamment
avec durire au départ en Allemagne c'est
pour dire que si c'est de l'orfèvrerie
on ça explique tout hein la qualité la
beauté et la complication la la maîtrise
et le le le doité je dirais du du
graveur qui n'a pas le droit à l'erreur
on travaille avec des matériaux qui sont
très
nobles le papier chiffon aujourd'hui
c'est très peu utilisé à part les
billets de banque hein c'est c'est on
est encore dans dans le le matériau
ancien et dans dans la pureté le cuivre
quand il est gravé c'est un
talisement c'est c'est ça attire donc il
y a il y a quelque chose de magique j'ai
découvert cette technique ça fera
bientôt plus qu'une trentaine d'années
et je suis j'aime beaucoup le détail
passer énormément de temps sur une
réalisation c'est une technique qui me
convient parfaitement c'est une activité
à la fois intellectuelle quand on grave
et de la précision de l'artisanada au
niveau de l'impression on a un équilibre
qui qui amène une certaine plénitude
chez le
graveur